consider a triangle pqr with sides 25 39
and 56 units
how do we find the area of this triangle
we don't have the height or the base but
we have been given the length of all
three sides
since we've been given only the length
of the sides we know we have to use the
heron's formula and to use the formula
we need the semi-parameter of the
triangle
let's zoom out and find the
semi-parameter which is s
the parameter will be 25 plus 39 plus 56
the sum of all three sides
and the semi-parameter will be the
parameter divided by 2.
this sum equals 120
the semi-parameter will be 120 by 2
which equals 60 units
we have found the semi-parameter
but how do we use the heron's formula
how do we find the area of triangle pqr
the area of triangle pqr will equal
square root of s multiplied by
s minus a multiplied by s minus b
multiplied by s minus c
where a b and c are the three sides of
the triangle
in this case s is 60
a can be 25
b 39 and c 56 units
we just need to be a little careful with
the calculations here as the numbers
when multiplied get really big
the area would equal square root of 60
multiplied by 60 minus 25 multiplied by
60 minus 39 multiplied by 60 minus 56
that will equal
square root of 60 multiplied by 60 minus
25 is 35
multiplied by 60 minus 39 is 21
multiplied by 60 minus 56 is 4.
think about the product of these numbers
it will be massive
the worst thing you could do here is
multiply these numbers to find the
product
in our videos based on square roots we
had seen that if the number is big we
should use the prime factorization
method to find the square root
and to use the prime factorization
method we have to reduce all the numbers
to their prime factors
let's look at the number 60 to start off
60 can be written as 2 times 2 times 3
times 5.
35 can be written as 5 multiplied by 7.
twenty one can be written as three
multiplied by seven
and four can be written as two times two
the next step in the prime factorization
method was to start making groups of two
same numbers
there are four twos
they can be written as two multiplied by
two
multiplied by two multiplied by two
apart from that there are two threes
we can write it as three times three
two fives written as five times five
and two sevens as seven times seven
to get the square root of these numbers
we pick one number from each pair
multiply them and remove the square root
sign
it will equal two multiplied by two
multiplied by three multiplied by five
multiplied by seven
that gives us 420 square units
the formula is pretty simple it is just
the calculations we need to be careful
about
another important thing you need to
remember here is the units of the answer
the units of area are always in squared
terms
think about the other formula of the
area of the triangle
it's half base multiplied by height
in this formula it's easy to understand
the units as units of base and height
are multiplied to get squared units
but how do we get squared units here
look at the formula carefully
four lengths are multiplied
so the units would be square root of
units raised to four
that gives us unit squared which is the
same as squared units